اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من نابلس اهلا بكم
الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل ضابط وجندي
واصابه اخرين جنوبي القطاع ما يرفع عدد
قتلاه منذ بدء العمليه البريه الى
17 كما قال ان تقديراته لحسم المعركه في
خانيونس
ستستغرق اشهرا في وقت بثت الجزيره صورا
لهجوم كتائب القسام على خيام جنود
اسرائيليين
اسفر عن مقتل عشره جنود في منطقه جحر
الديك عشرات الشهداء في غارات اسرائيليه
على مناطق سكنيه شمالي قطاع غزه وفي الضفه
الغربيه استشهد تسعه اشخاص على الاقل
برصاص قوات الاحتلال في مناطق عده بينهم
خمسه في مخيم نور شمس في طولكرم في حين
كشف مسؤول امريكي ان واشنطن بدات تسمع
انتقادات من اصد لقائها وشدد على ان
تعرضها للضغط ليس من مصلحه
اسرائيل احتجاجات مستمره لاهالي المحتجزين
الاسرائيليين تطالب بتحريرهم عبر صفقه
تبادل فورا واقاله رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي ووسائل اعلام اسرائيليه تقول
ان مجلس الحرب سيبحث منحا جديدا لصفقه
تهدف الى اعاده المختطفين من جهتها اكدت
حماس رفضها لاي مفاوضات للتبادل ما لم
توقف الحرب على
غزه الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل جندي
واصابه اثنين اخرين في هجوم بمسيره ملغمه
عند الحدود اللبنانيه وحزب الله اللبناني
يقول انه استهدف اربعه جنود اسرائيليين
شرق مستوطنه سعسع وحقق اصابات مؤكده كما
قصف قوات اسرائيليه في موقعين واوقع
اصابات الى
اللقاء
n